I always wanted to be a video that's one
of my check marks so I got to say I did
become a video ho do bank do a stop
yeah what can you tell me about the
Sally Walker experience I might have
died and we was an all-black we were
really out of a graveyard and it was in
that Manson who shot the you know that's
where she shot the video and this the
backup dancers were playing he looked
great as always and I was just happy
that I got the opportunity to be in the
video with my other sister mayham
basically yeah he won me was shot by
Cupid's but Jacuzzi Whoopie what was
Iggy like spheres and pretty and I was
just I just would get I would catch
myself there and I heard me like here
she's taller than I thought and her body
is thick it's that air you know what
surprised you about shooting a music
video everything outside and drag I will
only do this for you girl
well for any other celebrity as well but
damn being outside little Sally Walker I
was like [ __ ] I'm not ready to kill
this [ __ ] myself y'all want me to hurry
up with this let me help y'all let me
bury the [ __ ] yeah it was that was
probably the most shocking is being in
track cuz when I talk about the videos
that over time for me indoors we're
gonna have fear slide but I'm in the
wilderness like he asked for you
specifically like how did that come to
you I think so I mean I don't know why
but in my head yes I definitely think
she specifically picked people and she
had James Charles doing her makeup life
she put song yeah okay she know what she
was doing any so sickening video and I'm
happy to be a part of it and it was give
it me very covet and that you know I
love American horror not to them if
y'all need me call me y'all want me to
die whatever I do is drinks I'll do it
you're here for a gig no matter what the
gig is with some exceptions no I mean
I'm gonna do
at the end of the day I don't care as
long as I don't get hurt on it and crazy
[Music]